(bright electronic music)
- [Narrator] Hong Kong is
Cantonese for "fragrant harbor."
And the scent that defines
this city is incense.
One of the rarest kinds has
one very special ingredient.
(foreign language)
This Great Big Story is inspired by ...
Genesis.
(bright electronic music)
(foreign language)
Wah Yuen has one of the
last shops in Hong Kong
that hand rolls incense from agarwood.
(foreign language)
Agarwood incense smells like
nutty wood and sweet vanilla.
But this scent is expensive.
About one pound of quality agarwood
could cost over $60,000.
And a high quality pice of
agarwood is hard to find.
(gentle music)
Agarwood is created
out of aquilaria trees.
But when the tree is
healthy, it is odorless.
The scent comes from an oil
that is emitted when the tree is damaged.
(foreign language)
While today many people rely on factories
for incense production,
it is Wah Yuen's hope
that the traditional way
of hand rolling agarwood
is passed on to future generations.
(soft music)
(foreign language)